howdy ho reject those we're gonna watch
ourselves gravity falls today thank you
so much for being here leave a like if
you can that'd be very much appreciated
also make sure to check us out on
patreon over there we cover the full
length watch along as we sync up with
the time code for gravity falls bunch of
other shows over there as well and the
boys over at prepper thank you for
helping us edit down these highlights
and swinging action people
[Music]
detective welcome to a world of mystery
stan pines the tax collector you found
me no
that's a good trick
yeah
which one of these is the trapdoor mr
pine
you are our big winner
my one and only dream which was to
possess money
huh just sign here for the money you bet
oh
you just sand over the mystery shack to
little old me smart
ah you might want to take another look
there
the shack is hereby signed over to
sucker lemon
come here hon i need your arms
i'll get you stamper pines
i'll get you all no you won't want to
see what else is on tv yeah okay yeah
all right my favorite part's the theme
song
[Music]
meta jokes
he can't tell when it's a tax collector
or not but he can tell when he's being
pranked for a bunch of money
mommy
this intro's different
little guy to black space nine it's a
pawn stop stealing the tiny horses they
like it better in here don't you baby
oh
dipper wins again yo mabel can you pass
me that brain in the jar the lady won i
got it thanks but mabel's taller what no
she's not we're the same height we've
always been
that hat you were a hat man
[Music]
yup she's got exactly one millimeter on
you what ah
ring dipper this millimeter is just the
beginning i'm evolving into the superior
sibling
you know dipper i've always wanted a
little brother who knew i already had
one
i was awoken by the sound of mockery
where is it show me the object of
ridicule
one millimeter hey hey don't get short
with your sister
i hope you don't think little of him
yeah and and uh he's short
dude maybe you should lay off a tiny bit
tiny zeus is in on it now
[Laughter]
dipper will forget he's got a three two
one short-term memory
well done legends of miniature buffalo
and giant squirrels have led me to
believe there are height-altering
properties hidden deep within the forest
book has everything
[Music]
heavens
how cute
oh wow we can do that thought experiment
about the duck sized horses
is that mountain lion tiny or just far
away in perspective
[Laughter]
oh no
they could still hurt you
[Laughter]
that's so cute
[Music]
oh god yes
how big do you want to get
oh cool
smaller
bigger
too big
no bueno hey guys notice anything
different about me
holy hot sauce you've grown an extra
millimeter
what
make it two just to be safe
what can i say sis growth spurt
something tells me i've got another
growth spurt coming on right now
[Music]
give it up dipper
oh
wow doesn't make any sense just a second
ago yours wait a minute this is some
kind of mess
hand over the feed your property or i'll
smash this jar with a bat and they'll
devour this shack with you inside
hey what's that huh
huh i grew myself using this magic
flashlight
let me see that thing why'd you reveal
your secrets for you later
no
yes
[Music]
dk mode
be careful guys
your bodies are never going to be the
same proportions they're going to make
him big maybe he didn't see us use it
and doesn't know it's a magic flashlight
that can grow and shrink things
[Laughter]
[Music]
no
cool
[Music]
come on did you read about it somewhere
lean closer and i'll tell you well don't
mind if i
hide
this maze of mirrors is your best idea
that i'm taking credit for yet
my ears always been this big i'm always
surprised that he has hair
one
day i'll shrink stand and take the shack
for myself
y'all be helpless to stop me and if any
of you step out of line
no
[Music]
the ice cream truck is here
oh come on
oh no jacobs i'm coming that's
terrifying you get killed
bond with it
we gotta get out of here and save stan i
know
i will see you later
[Laughter]
i have a plan
[Music]
smart
that's creative
i love these like perspective blurs they
put on things to enhance the tiny
we need to get higher yeah especially
you because you're short
what cute little thing are you off to
you cute little cutie face i'm gonna
annihilate my arch enemies entire family
oh
okay
yay
that's your lover how could you he's
heading to shrink stan oh fine discount
dollar if only you could fly us back to
the mystery shack
maybe it can
what are you doing yes
you can't control that
[Music]
you can totally control it
i'm sorry gummy friend it's for the
greater good oh one of those infernal
gummy koalas has gotten into my perfect
hair
my feet stand looking like this get the
flashlight
quick get in front and i'll regrow you
okay
wait you're gonna grow us back to equal
height right
oh [ __ ]
i'm acting weird you're the one who
keeps calling me names and stuff oh what
you mean like little don't say it little
dipper
[Music]
well well stanford it appears i've
finally gotten the best of huh yeah what
all right something's definitely
different here you're sharp cat seuss
never you'll never find stan on the
second door to the left down the hall
stanford i'm coming for you
i'm the guy who put together that
shrinking device you kept teasing me
mabel like all day what was that all
about
i guess it's that you're better at me at
like everything
chess checkers ping pong
i guess i finally felt like i was
winning at something for once oh man now
i feel like a big jerk don't you mean
[Laughter]
and i walked into that one are we cool
we're cool am i cool you're cool
yes you're the coolest you come back
try and find me twerp
[Music]
let's get that flashlight before gideon
gets stand
careful oh
wow
no don't look into the quaff
this neck is really squishy keep your
voices down guys
tell my story oh
[Laughter]
watch the merchandise
oh my god it'll be you who pays uncle
stan is doomed not completely doomed to
his armpit
just
oh
it's tickle fight your business your
family everything will finally be mine
you're known to protect you now hmm
[Laughter]
i don't even know how to respond to this
no
maybe you know run your evil plan by
some friends next time huh workshop it
but first get your issues in order there
[Laughter]
and uh out the door
my light
you're the light of my life too pal
[Music]
hey
you let me keep my extra millimeter you
earned it she looks taller yeah well i
guess we should destroy this thing you
know so it doesn't fall into the wrong
hands and junk seems like the smart
thing to do
[Music]
there are you dudes are no
i guess we'll have to give the prize to
our runner-up winner
fiddleford h mcgucket
[Laughter]
how would you like 10 million
it's my dream come true
cross this town off our list
that is so upsetting
yep
i wish i could make you really tiny
i wish i could be really tiny
yeah that's right have a seat
that was fun that was a lot of fun
man gosh i've always wanted a device
like that
always wanted a device like that
i thought that there was a uh metaphor
for his insecurities about his girth
but apparently not it's just having to
do with just being made fun of it not
being able to take it
you know it's about the length
the length
you know
height height
height is a measurement of length
okay
so here we are
talking about this episode now
and uh
yeah i thought the way they realized
everything was really cool of you know
like i thought they
actually managed to come up with like
really creative ways of you know because
we've seen this scenario before
obviously you might flash something like
i shrunk the kids
when you're caught up in a dilemma of
being super duper tiny super dipper tiny
i should say like when they use the the
threads from the from the brush to
create a little rope to climb down i
think is really smart
and um even they get like really absurd
with how they fly back to the mystery
shack
and i think the ongoing themes that they
have here of or or the bits i should say
of like uncle stan now
like being the one with the mystery
shack and being the most unaware of the
magic although there was still that
tease from the first episode
that indicated that there is something
bigger in the mystery shack and he does
know something magical but it seems like
all the magical stuff that happened
seems to fly right under his nose where
he's just so unaware of things
and also the other theme of dealing with
the types of adolescent insecurities
that arise at this age whether it be
dealing with stuff like puberty love
height anything that
that i think the average youth can
really relate to i think is a really
cool way to segue into a lot of these
plots while maintaining the humor and
such something about the rules that was
kind of confusing to me
because when when when uh gideon was
talking to a little dipper
and uh mabel you know he he was able to
have just an ongoing conversation with
them but then
when they were like talking when they
were on his neck and shoulders he
couldn't hear them at all so
to me rules are important and uh the
show broke the rules
at that time and so i think they uh have
to keep a watchful eye out for that in
the writing you can't just give it a
pass
you gotta be uh gonna be more sharp and
on top of that but johnny should redo
this episode i think
no that's not necessary no they've got
to get something moving forward when
gravity falls season three comes out
yeah definitely they should be more
aware of things like when they revisit
things like this they got to keep
consistent
yeah man yeah i absolutely agree that
was very eloquently stated and uh yeah
yeah good length on that
definitely has a good length of uh
commentary right there yeah
and it was a girthy commentary too
though you know some nice nice thick
words in there some nice thick ideas
juicy points but uh yeah and it's fun to
see gideon continue to grow this status
as like their main nemesis foil person
at least for dipper and mabel and then
having that immediate undercutting with
the
like it's sort of the main
you know it's like the the b plot almost
becomes him trying to get the mystery
shack because the applause about mabel
and dipper but uh yeah i loved that he
is the sort of fulcrum of these two
conflicting ideas one is like he
definitely gets one over on mabel and
dipper and then with stan stan just yeah
is like so
either oblivious or used to all this
that he just outwits him just by being
and i i do appreciate just the absurdity
of that uh some great seuss moments in
this episode and two i was noticing i
really liked the way that they bothered
in certain scenes in certain moments to
draw
what looks like a different lens
for the angle you know you have things
that are blurred out in the foreground
and background to really enhance the
idea that they are
shrunk
so yeah i thought there were some nice
visual flourishes on top of you know a
pretty tight and very straightforward uh
you know gravity falls
high jinx plotline you know plus i
thought that was a really fun little bit
in the woods seeing all the different
sized animals learning how the crystals
work you know like uh
you know periodically getting more
expansion on just the weird different
areas of gravity falls and what mystical
magical strange and unusual things lie
in those places
so uh here's a good one and we got
steven root back as gideon's dad always
a pleasure he's popping up in every show
we watch lately he's good
good he's uh he's his dipper is dead i
mean not getting zapped
did not know that and then also learning
about gideon's mom
she's a repressed
manic housewife she's gonna explode
someday i know she's gonna turn on the
children she probably takes a lot of
antidepressants i hope they do a lot of
jokes about suffering mental health
definitely prozac jokes i think that's
what
more kids need to see
is people making fun of people's mental
health
um instability that's the way to go
about it that way you bring awareness
started off with comedy then go comedy
bad why that's the parent's job so show
does the insulting parents go that's not
funny let me tell you why and hence
art lives on
and see how you do that
see how you do that
anyway uh this was a delight as per
usual only have my one little nitpick
there
and other than that hell yeah i can't
wait to see how this unfolds because
they like that they have gideon as sort
of this through line that keeps it alive
that there's a
an enemy a rival because even
you know grunkle stan establishes him as
a rival
and um now we have bringing it back to
there's something at that shack we need
to unpack what's in that shack must get
hacked
in two all right so we can put that
mystery in the sack guys what do you
think about this episode leave your
thoughts down below thank you so much
for being here we'll catch you soon
[Music]